Hello,
freak bitches
call this patternicity the tendency to
find meaningful patterns in both
meaningful and meaningless noise,
and my thought experiment is imagine
you're a hominid on the plains of
Africa,
three and a half million years ago,
small brain Australopithecine and your
name is Lucy and you hear a rustle in
the grass.
Is that a dangerous Predator or is it
just the wind?
So if you assume that the rustle in the
grass is a dangerous Predator and it
turns out it's just the wind,
that's a type one error,
a false positive,
you thought a was connected to be but
but no harm you,
you just become skittish and conscious
or whatever.
But if you assume that the rustle in the
grass is just the wind and it turns out
it's a dangerous Predator,
your lunch,
you've just been given a Darwin award
for taking yourself out of the gene pool
early before reproducing.
So in other words,
it's better to just assume that all
things you think are connected,
all rustle in the grass are dangerous
predators and not the wind just in case.
And there's not.
There's not a big cost to pay for making
a type one error,
a false positive.
There is a higher cost for making a type
two error or false negative.
So we assume that this is the basis of
superstition and magical thinking.
We just assume that this is connected to
that you pull the slot and you do this,
you pull the slot machine,
you win or whatever,
and this is what skinner show back in
the fifties where you just randomly give
reinforcements to rats and pigeons and
whatever they were doing just before
they got rewarded.
They'll just repeat that behavior,
even if it's like twirling
counterclockwise twice or,
and that's the basis of superstition is
nothing wrong with their brains.
They're just trying to find causal
connections between events in the
environment and that's the basis of
survival.
So all of us are subject to making those
connections,
um,
are more gullible than others.
Say,
are more skeptical,
but for the most part,
all of us can easily be fooled if it's
done right.
That's,
that's the beauty of good cons,
good scams is that anybody could fall
for them.
Even smart people.
And if anything,
smart people are more likely to believe
weird things in this sense that once
they believe it,
they think they've drawn a connection.
They're better at rationalizing the
reasons why they believe,
then say less educated or less
intelligent people.
And so was people like Panacek will tell
you there's nothing better than an
audience of scientists at Mit.
Oh boy.
I can really fool them.
Uh,
because they think they're so smart.
I can't be full to wow.
Okay.
He must be doing something really,
really super psychic because I'm super
smart.
But.
Well no,
because all of our sensory apparatus
works the same.
And magicians know how to manipulate
your gaze,
your attention,
whatever,
and had a fool.
You.
What made him think it was big foot
shit?
Because they
smell it.
Smell it.
Maybe the bear had fucking a bad fish or
something.
They can't even agree on what it eats.
There were so sure as shit.
They can't agree.
They can agree on what bigfoot eats.
I'm good.
Who the fuck discovered that big foot
shit?
We gotta find that dude.
I met that I met.
That dude found the shit.
I had a conversation with him too.
It's a nice guy.
He's a teacher in a school.
Where did he find school teacher in
Oregon?
Funding out in the woods.
He's like,
this got to be big bullshit.
I'm going to take it with me.
I would think big food with lay logs
like this big as my thigh.
Just giant.
Ever see an elephant?
Take Shit and you see his ass hole open
up and he'd go,
good Lord.
Just flopping out of there.
There's a giant asshole.
That's what I imagined for pig foot.
Do you believe that there?
You know,
some people believe in bigfoot,
but they also believe in a different
kind of big foot.
It's like a different kind of like a
Christian church,
like a Lutheran.
They believe.
Yes.
We believe in bigfoot,
but we believe it's an interdimensional
beings.
I've heard that one.
What do you think the chances of that
being around?
Probably 100 percent.
Not just big flood.
I don't believe.
I believe it's real.
Okay.
I got to stop right here,
Bro.
I'm one eighth,
native American,
my grandmother's side,
and those are our people.
Our people have long known of the
existence of what we call the old Ma
with a bunch of different names for it.
The new name.
Every time I go up to Oregon or
Washington or do a seminar,
I asked the guys by show of hands who
believes in bigfoot and most of them do.
Yeah,
well,
most of them have heard stories,
you know,
I believed in it for the longest time
and I don't disbelieve in it today.
I don't disbelieve it,
but that's one you can make fun of.
But I found big foot.
I wouldn't be like,
oh,
I'd be like,
Oh shit,
that's real.
I definitely don't just believe in it
and you know what?
And I'll.
I'll just say it.
I think maybe he isn't or dimensional.
You know what I mean?
That's how.
That's my gut feeling.
It's ridiculous.
The things that are going on that are
getting covered up and nobody's talking
about like in the film,
I don't know if you saw that drug that
was made in the United States.
It was tainted with AIDS.
She was tainted with the Aids virus and
they said,
you know what,
well we can't lose this big batch of
drugs.
Let's send it to France.
What is.
How does.
I don't understand that though.
How does the AIDS virus get into that?
Sorry,
what is the AIDS virus?
You're talking about?
HIV.
I have no idea.
I have no idea,
but that's where the news report says
and say this.
Say that news report was all greening.
It was from 1985.
They might not know what the fuck they
were talking about now.
It would definitely was something that I
wanted was a head scratcher.
I actually have a guy,
there's a guy that works at it.
Marks Jim just got his phd and he was
going to go work for the company bear.
That was a company that sold.
They bear aspirin.
Everything.
That's a company that did it and I was.
One of the things he was.
He was talking about this like,
I don't know if I want to work for a
company like that.
Yeah.
We need to snopes that though.
Snopes that before you put it in the
documentary.
Actually,
actually,
yes,
we have a big team,
tastes tasted a few of those.
When we do these documentaries,
we have.
Look at this,
we have to fact check everything.
Make that a little larger please.
Here it goes.
Recently,
unearth documents show that the drug
company beer sold millions of dollars'
worth of injectable blood clotting
medicine.
Factor eight,
concentrate intended for haemophiliacs
to Asian Latin American in some European
countries in the mid 19 eighties,
although they knew it was tainted with
aids.
So yeah,
that's what I understand.
Like how something and aids go together.
That makes sense
for you.
This article is 10 years ago,
the company stopped selling the drug in
the United States in 1984,
but continue to sell it overseas for an
additional year.
The medicine was made using a combined.
Oh,
okay.
Plasma from large numbers of donors and
at the time there was no screening test
for eight for the aids virus,
so a tiny number of donors with AIDS
could inadvertently contaminate a large
batch.
Well,
they continue to sell the medicine
overseas in an attempt to avoid being
left with a large stock of a drug that
was no longer marketable in the United
States.
I have been so obsessed with this lately
like this,
and I know that I have like probably
we've talked about this before,
I talk to people probably get sick of me
talking about it,
but this concept of stressing your body
stressing exercise,
most people think exercise is good
because the exercise itself is good.
No,
the exercise of this exact exercise
itself is not good.
It's actually very stressful on your
body.
Um,
what's good is the stress response.
The body.
We've got a hard wired genetic program
that is conserved in plants,
insects,
bacteria,
um,
you know,
primates,
humans,
you know,
we're,
we're all,
we all have this response to stress.
And that response is to try to survive.
I need know I need to stay alive,
pass on my genes.
Obviously the stress response is much
stronger younger when you're younger or
the earlier in life because your body
knows you're not old enough to reproduce
for whatever,
you know,
hormones and things like that.
They're not being produced.
But um,
so the stress response,
which is like exercise causes stress,
thermal stress,
like heat cold,
and then there's all these compounds in
plants that are stressful to us that can
induce this,
but it's almost like the brain is
preparing for the next time it's going
to encounter stress.
It's like,
okay,
this is war.
I got to gather up the troops,
I gotta get this army.
We got to assemble this army because
that stress is going to happen again.
I got to be ready for war.
So it Kinda makes sense that you're in,
you're going to have a very profound and
positive effect in your brain.
And also in other parts of the body.
I'm,
you know,
the exercise itself.
Um,
it's funny because a lot of people do it
to lose weight or to mostly to lose
weight or you know,
become sexually attractive muscle mass,
which has other very important effects.
But people do it because they want to
look good,
and honestly a lot of.
There are a lot of people that say,
well,
exercise doesn't really play an
important role in losing weight.
It's nutrition.
You know what the right,
but exercise has a very important role
and that role is to to cause your body
stress so that you activate all these
really good and awesome jeans that are
helping you deal with stress.
And guess what?
Stress is happening right now.
Every time you breathe in oxygen,
your making stress,
you're,
you're generating byproducts that are
very dangerous.
So,
so exercise is good.